Hallo und herzlich Willkommen zum Chaos Radio 275, der Sendung, wo wir, wir, der Chaos Computer Club Berlin im weitesten Sinne sich einmal im Monat damit beschäftigen, aus einer, sagen wir, Nordperspektive auf die digitale Welt zu gucken und Dinge zu erklären. Manchmal auch zu zerklären. Das kommt ganz darauf an, um welches Thema es geht. Wir enden regelmäßig dabei, dass wir zwei Extreme haben. Entweder alles anzünden oder die Welt besser machen. Manchmal sogar beides. Ich bin sehr gespannt, wo wir heute landen werden. Mein Name ist Marcus Richter. Ich versuche, durch diese Sendung zu führen. Und wir sprechen heute über Barrierefreiheit. Nicht für die ganze Welt, sondern erst mal nur für den digitalen Teil, wie es beim Chaosradio so häufig ist. Vielleicht gehen wir auch noch woanders hin. Das müssen wir aber sehen. Wir sprechen also darüber, wie diese Welt, die für, sage ich mal, die engere Zielgruppe dieser Sendung ganz natürlich ist, vielleicht doch gar nicht so niedrigschwellig und zugänglich ist, wie man das manchmal glaubt. Woran das liegt, was man dagegen machen kann und wie das vielleicht alles besser wird, bespreche ich heute mit. Niclas Schmidt, er gibt Sensibilisierungs-Workshops und ist engagiert bei Ebel e.V. Hallo und guten Tag.
Das ist quasi sozusagen ein sich outen müssen. Ich möchte tatsächlich doch gerne nochmal über ein Thema, über das wir auch schon häufiger geredet haben, das nochmal anschneiden, was auch belächelt wird oder sozusagen für Stöhnen und Augenrollen sorgt, nämlich künstliche Intelligenz. Das kam ja vorhin schon mal sozusagen so ein bisschen auf bei der Untertitelung. Da wird das ja eben durch maschinelles Lernen gemacht. Oder andersrum. Untertitelungsalgorithmen funktionieren oft durch maschinelles Lernen. Und das ist das, was wir landläufig sozusagen unter künstliche Intelligenz hören, wenn in den Medien darüber berichtet wird. Ist die Hoffnung da, dass sich sozusagen durch die Technologisierung von Übersetzungsinterfaces in welcher Richtung auch immer, also A, das Problem der Zugänglichkeit generell verbessert, weil es halt sozusagen den Babelfisch im Ohr gibt oder man eine automatisierte Text-to-irgendwas-Übersetzung auf einem Display vielleicht hat, dass das besser wird und dass das kommt, dass man sich deswegen, dass sich deswegen vielleicht Anbieter auch ausruhen und sagen, das wird eh irgendwann von Technologie erschlagen, das müssen wir nicht von Hand machen. Und dass das aber auch eine Hoffnung ist, die man hat. Also spielt das eine Rolle? Oder ist das, wie in anderen Fachgebieten auch, es gibt dieses Schlagwort KI, wird alle unsere Probleme lösen und die Leute, die Ahnung von Accessibility haben, sagen so, nein.
Ja, wahrscheinlich mit der Blockchain dann erst mal.
Mit der Blockchain, immer natürlich.
Genau, draufhauen. Naja, also soweit ich weiß, ist das Problem oder ein Problem in dem Bereich die Datenlage. Also ich rede jetzt gar nicht unbedingt über so Sachen wie schlechte Datensätze, Dirty Data oder so, sondern wenn wir uns, ich weiß nicht, wie viele Sprachen es auf dieser Welt gibt, keine Ahnung, 200 oder so? Ich fisch jetzt in Trüben. Aber ich hab mich vor einer Weile mit einem Kollegen unterhalten, der im Linguistikbereich, im Verlagswesen arbeitet und der meint, das Problem ist, es gibt eine Handvoll Sprachen, wo so Daten überhaupt erhoben werden können, weil die viel gesprochen werden, weil es viele Aufzeichnungen gibt, viele Ressourcen, die man da irgendwie konsultieren kann. Das hört aber nach Deutsch, Englisch, Spanisch, Italienisch, Russisch war, glaube ich, auch noch dabei. Also, genau, Chinesisch auch, weil es eben, es kommt so drauf an, wie viele Leute sprechen das, wie aktiv wird das benutzt, welche Quellenlage gibt es? Und dann ist irgendwann ganz schnell Schluss.
Also das Ding ist ja bei den Modellen, zum Beispiel Facebook, benutzt, um alternative Texte für Bilder zu generieren. Ja, das spuckt halt Sachen raus, aber die können halt auch alle nicht hilfreich sein. Weil das Ding, also ja, das kann natürlich auch immer noch besser werden, wenn wir es natürlich auch wieder mit neuen Daten füttern. Aber es ist halt die Frage, kriegt man dann dieses Modell dann auf jedes Handy, auf jedes Gerät drauf, wenn das dann so riesig ist, wenn es die ganze Welt im Zweifel erklären muss. Das ist halt de facto, man muss ja Augen ersetzen, die das ganze Wissen, das wir im Leben ersammelt haben, um die Welt zu interpretieren. Das muss dieses AI-Model dann plötzlich machen. Und am Ende haben wir dann vielleicht so einen zentralisierten Dienst, wo wir alle unsere Bilder hochschicken und dann gibt uns das Bild zurück, dann sind wir wieder bei Privacy.
Also das heißt, für mich sozusagen, der ab und zu in dieser Sendung sitzt und diese Fragen stellt, wird die Zukunft technisch alle Probleme lösen, könnte man zusammenfassen, es ist hier so wie in anderen Bereichen auch vielleicht ja, aber das ist a, so unklar und b, noch in so weit der Zukunft, dass wir uns heute nicht darauf verlassen wollen. Ist das sozusagen vielleicht eine grobe Zusammenfassung, die man da treffen könnte?
Ja, aber im Bereich Accessibility tatsächlich noch zu verbinden mit einer deutlichen Warnung, nämlich das, was du vorhin gesagt hast. Es gibt dann zu viele Leute, die glauben auch, das funktioniert automatisch und wir müssen nichts anderes mehr machen. Also gerade bei automatisch erzeugten Untertiteln ist diese Gefahr sehr deutlich schon jetzt da.
Ich würde noch hinzufügen, ich sehe tatsächlich eine Chance und deshalb glaube ich, sind wir hier mit dem Thema halt auch irgendwie an einer sehr, sehr schönen Stelle im Chaosumfeld und in den Communities, die damit zu tun haben, weil es irgendwie auch dann doch um eine zwischenmenschliche Ebene geht und irgendwie um, also wenn wir Lösungen wollen, dann kommen wir nicht drum rum, dass wir miteinander ins Gespräch kommen sollten, dass wir irgendwie erstmal freundlich aufeinander zugehen, uns nicht irgendwelche Worte übel nehmen und verbieten, sondern sagen so, hey, komm, erstmal reden können und dann können wir uns drüber unterhalten, wie wir miteinander reden wollen vielleicht. Und um dann eben zu schauen, okay, also diese Community ist ja unglaublich, finde ich. Und da kommen super, super viele Sachen raus, ich glaube an der einen oder anderen Stelle, ja, muss man sich da irgendwie nochmal ein bisschen, muss man vielleicht den Fokus vielleicht nochmal irgendwie schärfen oder so und da auch deutlich machen, das ist jetzt hier nicht so just for fun. Es geht halt irgendwie um eine gelebte, ich würde fast sagen eine gelebte radikale Demokratie, wenn es um Zugänge geht. Egal ob offline, in der Hosenwelt oder digital.
Ich möchte zwei Fragen stellen, die sagen, die ein bisschen persönlich gefärbtes Interesse sind, aber die gerade wo du sagst, wir reden ja hier auf einer sehr institutionellen und gesellschaftlichen Ebene, die auch ans Kleine geht. Und das eine ist tatsächlich dieser Podcast, der auch zu einer bisschen größeren Frage kommt. Das Chaosradio ist eine Sendung, die den Anspruch hat, die Welt ein kleines bisschen besser dadurch zu machen, dass man Dinge erklärt. Ist sie barrierefrei? Auf gar keinen Fall. Was wir nämlich nicht haben, ist ein Transkript dieser Sendung. Das liegt aber daran, und da ist gleich die Frage verbunden, das können wir nicht leisten. Wir sind ein Trupp von Menschen, die das alle aus Spaß an der Freude machen, oder weil wir das Gefühl haben, das ist etwas, was die Welt braucht. Und wir investieren alle so viel, wie wir können. Und einen Transkript zu leisten, schaffen wir nicht. Aber natürlich ist es auch ein total valider Punkt zu sagen, ihr wollt halt nicht. Die Menschen, die das Chaosradio machen, brauchen das alle nicht. Und jetzt ist aber die Frage, das ist das eine. Man könnte also sagen, na ja, aber das ist eine Barrierefreiheit als das Ideal, das wir unbedingt erreichen wollen. Dann muss das eine Anforderung sein. Ein anderer Spruch, der mir aber bei dieser Problematik durch den Kopf geht, ist, eine Befreundin der Soziologin hat mal gesagt, oder ich weiß gar nicht, wo das herkommt, anyways, Individueller verzichtet es keine Lösung für gesellschaftliche Probleme. Das heißt, die Frage ist, wenn man jetzt im Nördernfeld ist, dann ist ja dieser Übergang fließend zwischen, das ist ein Projekt, wo jemand oder ein paar Leute Spaß an der Sache haben, dann aber genau nur so viel machen, wie sie Bock haben oder nicht. Muss man barrierefrei sein und letztlich dann sagen, okay, wenn ihr das nicht leisten könnt, dann sollt ihr bitte aber auch nicht den Podcast machen. Also jetzt ganz überzogen formuliert. Oder ist es auch okay, das nicht zu schaffen? Und ist das sozusagen ein valides Argument, solange es eben nicht ein sozusagen, was ist, wo man sich hinter versteckt?
Ich glaube schon, dass es ein valides Argument ist. Es muss auch ein sein. Weißt du, was einfach auch wichtig ist, ist so was wie gesunder Menschenverstand. Also wir reden ja an vielen Stellen einfach über gesetzliche Regelungen, letztlich gesetzliche Regelungen, weil es sonst keiner tut. Also da können wir ja auch mit sowas wie Frauenquoten oder so anfangen. Es braucht die einfach an manchen Stellen. Und gerade da, wo wir dann über kapitalistische Strukturen und sowas reden, aber ich sag mal da, wo wir über reibildiges Engagement reden und sieht das aus meiner Sicht, also das ist jetzt meine persönliche Meinung, ganz anders aus und was ich auch dabei noch wichtig finde, ist, das klang schon ein paar Mal an, ist halt dieser menschliche Faktor. Auch wenn man Mensch mit Einschränkungen ist, man braucht ganz oft nicht die perfekte Lösung, egal jetzt ob technisch oder nicht technisch, sondern ein sichtbares Bemühen, was auch immer dabei rauskommt. Aber auch dieses, es ist selbstverständlich, dass man dabei ist, auch wenn das gewisse Einschränkungen hat, für beide Seiten womöglich, ist auch erstmal okay, ist schon sehr schön. Und ich sag mal, ja, ich persönlich bedauere manchmal, dass es eine Menge Podcasts gibt, die für mich einfach verstoßen bleiben. Aber auf der anderen Seite, es gibt so viel Input schriftlich. Ich schaff's eh nicht.
Niclas, wolltest du auch noch?
Also ich glaube, ich finde es zum einen total cool. Wir haben ja in der Vorbereitung auch gemerkt, dass es ganz schön anspruchsvoll ist, uns alle miteinander digital zu verknüpfen. Ich komme aus einer Kinder- und Jugendarbeits-Ecke, wo es früher schon Learning by Doing hieß. Ich finde das manchmal auch echt ganz schön frustrierend. Ich glaube, wenn es um das Chaosradio geht oder andersrum. Ich habe ja den Kontakt zum Chaosradio letztes Jahr gesucht, weil ich eigentlich mal ein bisschen Staub aufwirbeln wollte im Chaosumfeld. Ich spadroniere da irgendwie immer schon seit einer Weile rum und hatte den Eindruck, ich glaube, ich fände es cool, wenn die Leute, die sich damit assoziieren, und wenn man sich fünf Minuten hinsetzt und überlegt, wie läuft das eigentlich bei uns in unserer Gruppe oder auf einem möglichen nächsten Offline stattfindenden Congress. Sich einfach nur mal die Frage zu stellen. Ich glaube, das ist ein wichtiger erster Schritt. Ich glaube, es geht darum, Schritte zu machen und auf dem Weg zu sein. Ich finde es total geil, was das Chaosradio Team mir auf die Beine stellt und dass wir diese Folge machen. Wenn am Ende dabei übrig bleibt, dass jemand überlegt, habe ich vielleicht noch Zeit, die Woche eine Transkription anzufangen oder nicht? Und selbst wenn nicht, und wenn du irgendwer zehn Minuten Zeit hat und sagst, aber ich gucke mal, ob ich den finde, der vielleicht Bock hat, eine Transkription zu machen. Jetzt nur um beim Beispiel zu bleiben. Oder hey ho, an die Leute da draußen, habt ihr nicht voll Bock, eine Transkription fürs Chaosradio zu machen? Das ist eure Chance, Ruhm und Ehre. Also so kann es halt laufen. Ich glaube, es geht darum, irgendwie auf dem Weg zu sein und ganz wichtig, nicht irgendwie mit so einem, auf so einem, ja ich weiß nicht, irgendwie auf so einem unangenehmen Schuldtrip, da gilt Tripp irgendwie zu sagen, oh Gott, sollen wir nicht einfach alles sein lassen, wenn wir hier nicht irgendwie das hinkriegen? Nee, wir sind alle auf dem Weg. Wir nutzen die Tools, die uns gerade zur Verfügung gestellt werden, um damit besser zu bauen.
Hat nicht jemand Lust da draußen, mal voll die geile Transkription für diese Radiosendung zu machen? Die andere Frage, die ihr...
Mit einer kurzen Zusammenfassung wäre auch schon geholfen. Also einfach um mal so, wir sind alle auf dem Weg.
Die andere sozusagen kleine, wirklich sehr ins Detail gehende Frage ist die, klar, wir fahren schon mal ganz kurz an, Screenreader und Gender Gap. Das fand ich eine total interessante Diskussion, als die damals aufkamen, weil es wurde ja darüber gesprochen, also HörerInnen, wie stellt man das textlich dar? Macht man das mit diesem Doppel-i? Macht man das mit dem Sternchen? Macht man das mit dem Unterstrich? Und da war eine Argumentation von vielen, na, mach das doch so und so. Niclas hat das, glaube ich, vorhin schon angeteased kurz, weil die Screenreader lesen das sonst falsch. Und da war ich auch so einerseits, andererseits. Einerseits kann ich das total gut verstehen, dass man sagt, hey, hier ist eine Gruppe von Menschen, die Sprache in einer bestimmten Art und Weise benutzt. Vielleicht könnt ihr euch auch nach denen richten. Andererseits dachte ich so, Screenreader, das ist doch jetzt wirklich Technologie. Und die Technologie muss ich doch der Sprache anpassen, um nicht umgekehrt. Aber wie bei allen diesen Dingen, kann ich das natürlich aus meiner hochfeil privilegierten Position natürlich total toll rumdenken und hab keine Ahnung von nichts. Deswegen würde ich bei Niclas auch anfangen, aber auch von Irmhild das gerne wissen wollen. Wie seht ihr das denn? Also am konkreten Beispiel, aber tatsächlich auch, das ist ja auch die weiterführende Frage, müssen sich zukünftige Entwicklungen an den derzeitigen technischen Stand von assistiven Systemen anpassen? Oder sind die auch in der Verpflichtung, Schritt zu halten?
Ja, also ich bin total dankbar, dass du da nochmal den Punkt aufkreist, weil das so ein Thema ist, was mich immer wieder extrem beschäftigt und wütend macht. Also ich bin da auch bei deiner Vermutung und finde, das kann ein Screenreader leisten. Also ich komme aber auch über Studien und Ausbildung irgendwie aus einer gewissen Denkrichtung und sage, okay, Sprache ist unser Zugang zur Welt, formt unser Denken und unsere Wahrnehmung. Und wenn wir uns jetzt gerade, weiß ich nicht, einig sind, dass zum Beispiel der Genderstern irgendwie das Mittel der Wahl ist, um das, was wir wahrnehmen wollen, uns zugänglich zu machen, dann soll doch bitte die Assistenztechnologie sich da mal nicht so haben. Damit sind wir aber schnell wieder in einem anderen Bereich, weil die Frage ist ja, wer steckt denn eigentlich hinter meiner Assistenztechnologie? Haben die Leute da ein Interesse dran? Ist das irgendwie, wie wir es schon ein paar Mal hatten, so ein obendrauf, so ein Plus, was noch mal hinten so drangeschoben wird? Ja, okay, das machen wir jetzt auch noch. Oder steckt da irgendwie auch ein gewisses anderes Interesse hinter irgendwie Geldgenerierungen oder irgendwie weiß ich nicht was. Also, ich glaube, wenn ich so grob überschlage, wenn es jetzt um Screenreader wirklich geht und um akustische Ausgabe, würde ich, komme ich so auf sechs, sieben verschiedene Softwareprodukte. Also jetzt sowohl Desktop als auch irgendwie mobile Geräte. Und da steckt immer eine Firma hinter. Und wir hatten in der Vorbereitung ja auch diese Frage, wie funktioniert eigentlich ein Screenreader? Das Schöne daran ist, ohne da jetzt ins Detail gehen zu wollen, die funktionieren gar nicht alle gleich. Also in der Frage, wie holen die sich ihre Daten aus dem, was ich vorhin als User Agent beschrieben habe, aus dem Browser oder aus meinem Media Player oder aus meinem Text Editor, whatever, das machen die nicht alle auf die gleiche Art und Weise. Da kocht jeder irgendwie, jede Firma irgendwie so ein bisschen ihr eigenes Süppchen. Und wir sind, also ich kenne eine, es gibt NVDA, läuft auf Microsoft Windows System, das ist ein Open Source Projekt. Und es gibt einen Screenreader in der Linux Welt, den ich kenne, sonst möglicherweise kommt er jetzt ein zweiter. Und der Rest ist proprietär.
Also heißt das sozusagen, also ich hatte ja schon sozusagen ab und zu gefragt, haben wir hier dasselbe Problem wie in anderen Facetten der Digitalisierung auch? Heißt das auch hier die Aussage, mein Screenreader kann das nicht, ist eigentlich nur das Potemkinche Dorf für, wir haben hier einen weiteren Bereich der Digitalisierung, der voller proprietärer Geräte ist, wo nicht der Nutzer oder die Nutzerin entscheidet, was man den Geräten machen kann, sondern die Hersteller, die ihre Geräte so zumachen, dass man sie nicht ändern kann?
Ja, ich glaube, da würde ich einfach mal so ein solides Ja dran nehmen.
Irmhild anscheinend nicht, weil wir haben, wir sehen uns auch im Bild und die wird ganz bedächtig und skeptisch mit dem Kopf gewackelt, wenn ich das richtig interpretiere.
Ja, also ich würde es ein bisschen differenzierter sehen oder vielleicht einen zusätzlichen Aspekt beisteuern wollen. Also grundsätzlich bin ich auch der Meinung, natürlich kann die Technik das und sie muss es auch können. Es ist auch ein Problem, proprietary Geräte, aber nicht nur. Also die Sache ist tatsächlich ein bisschen komplizierter, weil A, wie Niclas eben schon sagte, die Art und Weise, wie jetzt, wenn wir am Beispiel Screenreader bleiben, das, was da vorgelesen werden soll, in den Screenreader reinkommt, halt unterschiedlich ist. Und das bedeutet auch, dass es wieder teilweise abhängig davon ist, wie dieser Inhalt, der da in den Screenreader rein soll, markiert ist. Also ich schreibe zum Beispiel gerade einen Text, der in einer, also digital, in einer barrierefreien E-Book erscheinen soll. Und ich bin angehalten, jeden englischen Begriff, den ich verwende, auch als englisch auszuzeichnen, damit die Screenreader den korrekt vorlesen. Weil der Screenreader kann ja im Unterschied zu einem menschlichen Leser nicht mal eben unterscheiden, das ist jetzt deutsch und das spreche ich deutsch aus, und das ist jetzt englisch und das muss ich englisch aussprechen. Das muss ihm ja gesagt werden. So, das ist so der eine Punkt. Der zweite Punkt, den ich aber vor allen Dingen beitragen will, ist, das Ganze hängt auch noch damit zusammen, wie die verschiedenen Benutzerinnen und Benutzer ihre Screenreader einstellen. Weil viele, die Screenreader benutzen, gerade wenn sie es schon lange gewöhnt sind, stellen zum Beispiel die Geschwindigkeit sehr hoch. Das heißt, sie lassen sich viel viel schneller als sehende oder auch nicht hörende Menschen die Sachen vorlesen. Das ist wie so eine Art Überfliegen beim Lesen. Und sie stellen ganz oft spezielle Einstellungen, was eben Satzzeichen, Sonderzeichen und Ähnliches angeht. Also es ist ja die Frage, ob ich einen Satz einfach so, wie ich ihn sprechen würde, vorlese oder ob ich sage, ja, Komma, hier geht der Satz jetzt weiter, Komma und so weiter. Und da kommen wir wieder in so einen Bereich, wo man sagen muss, naja, muss man halt ein bisschen differenzierter sehen. Das wollte ich noch ergänzen, bitte. Nicht dagegen, sondern nur ergänzen.
Also auch das Technologie, die beherrscht sein will. Auch das ist ja wieder sozusagen eine Frage der Zugänglichkeit. Wer kann eigentlich wie seine eigenen Geräte einstellen? Und die aber auch beherrschbar sein muss. Also die man auch sozusagen. Und dann wiederum auch ein Standardproblem. Das ist ja tatsächlich, aber was mich schon häufig begegnet ist, dass eigentlich immer gesagt wird, wir hätten gerne den einen Weg, wie Daten präsentiert werden, nämlich so, dass sie möglichst einfach verarbeitet werden können und dass nachvollziehbar ist, was da passiert. Wir haben jetzt ganz viele Teilbereiche gestriffen. Ich würde einen heute gerne auslassen, die rechtliche Seite, weil da hatten wir eigentlich eine Expertin für eingeladen, die ist dann ganz kurzfristig verhindert gewesen. Ich würde nur das in dem Sinne aufgreifen, dass ihr ja gesagt habt, es gibt zumindest im geschäftlichen Bereich und vor allen Dingen, was offizielle Stellen angeht, gewisse Vorschriften, dass Barrierefreiheit gewährleistet sein muss. Und ich will jetzt gar nicht in die Tiefe gehen, also ich frage, was für Gesetze gibt es wie, wer steckt dahinter und so weiter und so fort, sondern einfach zum Schluss der Sendung nochmal so drei Sachen in Richtung praktische Lebenshilfe zum Einstieg in ein barrierefreieres Leben bieten und das erste eben auf diesen Bereich abzielen. Wenn ich jetzt jemand bin, der davon betroffen ist, dass dein Angebot das eigentlich sozusagen mir Zugang verschaffen möchte, das nicht tut, weil eben diese Barrierefreiheit oder diese Zugänglichkeit fehlt, was kann ich da tun? Wie ist da die Situation? Da kann man wieder einen Vergleich zum Datenschutz ziehen. Da gibt es die Datenschutzgrundverordnung. In der Theorie werden erfindliche Bußgelder verhängt. Praktisch ist das dann immer so eine Frage. Wie ist das denn hier in dem Bereich? Kann ich was machen, wenn ich betroffen bin und sage, so hier, das geht so eigentlich nicht, ihr müsst mir eigentlich Zugang gewähren? Gibt es da Mittel und Wege?
Zumindestens in der Sachen der EU-Richtlinie, die ja für öffentliche Stellen gilt, gibt es diesen Feedback-Mechanismus. Aber, und da gibt es dann auch Überwachungsstellen, aber die verhängen weder Bußgelder, die versuchen das halt durchzusetzen irgendwie. Aber es ist halt schwierig einer Behörde, ein Bußgeld anzudrohen, weil wer treibt das ein, das Bußgeld? Richtig eine andere Behörde. Und da beißt sich halt die Schlange in den Schwanz. Das wird dann im öffentlichen Sektor mit dem European Accessibility Act nochmal ein bisschen was anderes, wenn auch wirklich dann Leute auch sagen können, ey, du musst mir das zugänglich machen, das klage ich mir im Zweifel auch ein. Das ist ein bisschen schwierig, aber es gibt diesen Feedback-Materialismus und die Behörden müssen darauf reagieren. Und ich glaube, der schlimmste, was, glaube ich, noch vor uns geht, ist so Verbandsklagen prinzipiell. Aber das ist natürlich so die höchste mögliche Eskalationsstufe. Und das ist dann auch immer schwierig, dann am Ende auch zu machen.
Das hört sich an, es gibt theoretisch Werkzeuge, praktisch ist es aber schwierig.
Ja, es gibt dazwischen auch noch die sogenannten Schicksverfahren. Also das habe ich auch schon mal gemacht, weil die Behörde, an die ich mich gewendet hatte, nämlich schlicht nicht reagiert hat, was ich natürlich nicht so gut fand, verständlicherweise. Und deswegen habe ich mich dann sozusagen an die zuständige Überwachungsstelle gewendet. Und die ist dann auch tätig geworden, was nur bedeutet, dass sie einen Brief schreibt und der Behörde dann sagt du, du, du, du, du. Und daraufhin wiederum hat die Behörde einen Brief geschrieben und gesagt, ja, aber die Sache ist ja ganz kompliziert. Und wir sind ja eigentlich nicht zuständig. Und deswegen gilt die Richtlinie, ja, wenn wir das eng auslegen, hier gar nicht. Man beachte, ja, waren alles Juristen, die da miteinander kommuniziert haben. Aber wir sind ja ganz großzügig. Und in der nächsten Version verbessern wir die Barrierefreiheit. Das ist dann tatsächlich auch passiert, man höre uns staunen. Ob es für die übernächste Version dann auch noch gilt, werden wir sehen. Aber ja, also das ist tatsächlich noch ein Problem, ist aber auch irgendwie blöd, weil das ist halt das Problem, das wir eben schon hatten. Die Leute, die gerade bei öffentlichen Stellen, die die Webseiten barrierefrei machen, müssen das nachträglich tun. Es ist eben nicht von vornherein mitgedacht worden. Dann haben sie es mühsam gemacht, haben es aber nur halb geschafft. Dafür gibt es auch oft Gründe. Und dann kommen so irgendwelche Leute und sagen, ihr habt aber nicht, ihr habt aber nicht, ihr habt aber nicht. Und dann geht das so einen rechtlichen Weg, der hilft eigentlich keinem wirklich, außer eben, wenn es gut läuft, Bewusstsein zu schaffen. Und da wäre es eigentlich schön, wenn es da andere Wege gäbe.
Das klingt für mich so ein bisschen so, als ob das eine ehrenwerte, aktivistische Arbeit ist, solche Verfehlungen sozusagen anzufechten oder aufzuzeigen. Aber im praktischen Leben nicht konkret und schnell Hilfe angezeigt ist durch sowas. Gehen wir die umgedrehte Seite an. Wenn ich jetzt ein Projekt mache, die Frage geht dann auch so ein bisschen an Dennis, der sozusagen als Dienstleister auch fungiert für Leute, die sagen, ich habe hier ein digitales Angebot. Das soll jetzt auch barrierefrei sein. Was sind denn gute Dinge, die man, wir haben es ja schon besprochen, dass man am besten gleich am Anfang an dran denkt, die man mitbringt, wenn man den Bordstein, um das Bild vom Anfang zu benutzen, nicht so hoch machen will.
Na also es fängt einfach an, sich zu beschäftigen, was möchte man erreichen und wie möchte man es erreichen. Also im Designprozess schon anzufangen. Da gibt es echt wirklich einfache Tools, die mit den Kontrastwerte einchecken. Da muss man gar nicht mehr wissen, welcher genaue Wert das ist. Das Ding sagt einem nur grün oder rot. Oder ja oder okay. Die sind auch zum Teil selber nicht barrierefrei, diese Tools. Aber das ist so der erste Weg, wo man anfangen kann. Ich finde, diese WCAG ist ein ultra hilfreiches Ding, weil natürlich ist da sehr viel normativ geregelt. Also eine Webseite muss das und das können. Und der Nutzer oder die Nutzerin kann jederzeit seine Schriftgröße ändern und es darf nichts kaputt gehen. Aber was immer darunter ist, sind immer so so könntest du das erreichen Vorschläge. Das sind wirklich so Sachen, da gibt es halt so sehr abstrakte Sachen wie die Nutzerin muss immer wissen, wo sie sich auf der Webseite gerade befindet. Wie erreicht man denn das jetzt ehrlich gesagt? Und da steht da drunter so ein Hinweis, ja du könntest eine Sitemap anbieten oder so eine Brotchrome Navigation, Birdcamp Navigation oder das oder das oder das. Und so kannst du es erreichen. Das ist ultra praktisch, weil es halt sehr quasi einer praktischen Umsetzung gelegen ist. Und das lohnt sich sehr, einfach da reinzulesen, zu gucken, was könnte denn der Weg sein, das zu erfüllen, diese Voraussetzung, finde ich zumindest.
Und ich glaube, ich kann da Dennis total zustimmen. Und soweit ich in die WCAG reingeguckt habe, finde ich, ist das eine super Ressource. Was wir mit Be Able e.V. machen, ist ja auch, so ein bisschen uns da einzumischen. Also weniger jetzt wie bei der vorherigen Frage auf so einer rechtlichen Ebene, sondern wir versuchen da eben auch ein Angebot zu machen, um mit auch im Zweifelsfall Unternehmen zusammen Designprozesse mit Inklusion zusammenzubringen und von vornherein das eben mitzudenken. Da geht es manchmal nicht nur um digitale Produkte, da geht es manchmal auch um so richtig noch so Dinge, die man so anfassen kann, die so aus Elementen bestehen. Aber ich glaube, wo meine Motivation auch immer so herkam, war Verständnis bei den Leuten hervorrufen. Ich glaube, das geht nur über das Kennenlernen der Lebensumstände. Ich würde fast so weit gehen und sagen, nur was ich selbst erlebt habe, kann ich wirklich richtig nachfühlen, nachvollziehen. Auf einer Ebene, die über so ein rein rationales Ah ja, okay, dass es logisch hinausgeht. Und ich glaube, wenn der Punkt erreicht ist, wie viele Leute mir nach irgendwelchen Aktionen noch Mails geschrieben haben und gesagt haben, bei jeder Ampel fällt mir jetzt plötzlich auf, die klickt und piept, und ich kann da einen Knopf drücken. Das habe ich vorher nie gemerkt. Hier sind ja überall so Riffelflaster, um jetzt so ganz klassische Barriereabbau-Sachen in der begehbaren Welt anzubringen. Das hat mir immer wieder gezeigt, das macht total viel Sinn, sich damit auseinanderzusetzen. Und ich glaube, da gibt es gute Vereine, an die man sich wenden kann, wenn man halt Bock drauf hat vielleicht.
Man kann ja auch ruhig noch größer denken. Wenn schon, wenn schon, würde ich vorschlagen. Das Ganze würde ja auch viel einfacher werden, wenn Menschen mit welchen Einschränkungen auch immer viel selbstverständlicher auch überall wären. Sei es in der Schule, sei es im Arbeitsleben, sei es im Alltag, im Verein oder sonst wo. Weil dann nämlich auch jeder jemanden kennt und wie Niclas auch sagte, zumindest eine Idee hat, was das eigentlich bedeutet, wenn jemand nicht sehen, nicht hören, nicht laufen kann, weiß der Geier. Und dann auch daran denkt, das ist doch das Entscheidende, dass man überhaupt, das haben wir ja schon rausgearbeitet, auf die Idee kommt, ja, mal darüber nachzudenken, dass es eben nicht alles so funktionieren, wie ich gerade selber, der ich als Web- oder als Softwareentwickler oder weiß der Geier was, da sitze und jetzt gerade meinetwegen auch nur den Akkuschrauber nur für Männerhändedesign.
Anfangen drüber nachzudenken. Ich glaube, das ist sozusagen der Punkt, wo ich tatsächlich die Sendung gerne beenden würde, weil ich hoffe, das haben wir erreicht. Wenn jetzt sozusagen nicht Dennis Irmhild oder Niclas sagen, nein, wir haben diesen einen wichtigen Punkt noch vergessen, den müssen wir unbedingt noch besprechen, möchte ich euch an dieser Stelle eine kurze Pause geben, um diese Gelegenheit zu vergreifen. Und ansonsten sagen, lieber Dennis, liebe Irmhild, lieber Niclas, vielen Dank, dass ihr heute zu Gast wart, dass wir alle so geduldig zusammen durchgestanden haben, dass wir hier technisch auch zusammenkommen konnten und für die schönen Einblicke, die ihr uns gegeben habt und auch eben das möglich machen, das mal anfangen, drüber nachzudenken. Weil ich kann jetzt sozusagen wieder nur anekdotisch von mir selbst erzählen. Diese, ähm, diese, die Freude sozusagen, also die Fröhlichkeit, möchte ich fast sagen, mit der ihr in das Thema mitnehmt. Und auch so ein bisschen das Beruhigende. Es ist mir so ein bisschen peinlich, weil ich sozusagen der bin, der am wenigsten irgendwie davon betroffen ist und jetzt trotzdem immer so Angst davor habe, das Thema anzufassen. Aber diese Fröhlichkeit zu sagen, hey, es ist schon total gut, wenn wir es überhaupt versuchen. Und wir streben die Perfektion an. Und es ist aber auch klar, dass es nicht im ersten Schritt erreicht sein muss. Das finde ich auch ein Gedanken, den ich mir einfach mal hinter die Ohren schreiben sollte, um da keine Berührungsängste mehr zu haben. Also in diesem Sinne, vielen Dank. Vielen Dank auch ans Chaosradio Team, das diese Sendung organisiert, zusammengestellt und redaktionell geplant hat. Vielen Dank auch an die Gebärdendolmetscherinnen, die möglich gemacht haben, dass wir so flüssig und zusammen sprechen konnten. Vielen Dank an euch, liebe HörerInnen, dass ihr wieder dabei wart. Das war das Chaosradio 275. Und mir bleibt nur noch eine Sache zu sagen. Lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.